[Music]
now at the time in the 80s obviously
there was there were there was no
internet I means act like I was coming
I'm coming from a very small town in
Quebec the news that we get at the time
was from fanzine you know like Starlog
or fantastic films and I still vividly
remember going to the I don't know -
newspaper store you know we're having
all those magazines and seeing Harrison
Ford I mean Rick Deckard and gaff in the
spinner and I still vividly remember the
first time I saw that image and the
emotion it created inside me the
excitement of having the strong
impression that it was something new
that I haven't never seen before that
strong emotion was present at the time
when I saw the movie for the first time
was really the first time that I felt
that someone was bringing in in the
future showing me what our future could
be like and dark it was but exciting it
could be in the same time and that it's
an experience I will never forget the
charmers name was gaff I'd seen him
around the first one I saw and I was
raised with is the original one with the
voice-over etc I know that was the movie
I embraced at the beginning and that at
the time I didn't that was not aware of
all that that Ridley was frustrated
about this version I am I thought that
the voice-over gave at the time I felt a
kind of film noir element to the that
would feel felt logic to the the the the
mood of the movie and I just deeply felt
in love with that film but I still
remember the emotion I got III when I it
was written on the screen and November
2009 team Los Angeles and then the first
frame that we were seeing of early that
first landscape that has an aliens who
were allowed to see it was a very
impressive experience to see that movie
on the big screen for the first time
it was the birth of BHS the birth of and
so Blade Runner was one of the first one
I got for the first time I I was older I
was the owner of them film that's an
experience it was not because I could
book you I could watch over and over and
over again so I did that he destroyed
the tape I mean it's like I watch it so
many times the first time I saw it what
a strike to me was really to have the
impression that I was a time-traveling
machine that I was embracing the future
and as scary that vision was impressive
it was I had strongly and that an
impression that I was worth missing
something that I was not allowed to see
which was the future it was like a
prescience you felt it was coming you
felt that what they showed us was in
some ways you feel it in from your
intuition say that's the other look like
that weird that's where we are going
that was it was like the first time that
that strong impression that it was a
visionary experience I'm not surprised
that the world is just catching up
toward later on or more and more for the
best and the worst
[Music]